Hey
it's just me and you nobody else is here
your secrets are fine it's just the two
of us but I got a question for you do
you really believe your dreams are going
to become a reality with you keeping all
your bad habits you really believe that
you really believe your dreams are going
to become a reality with you playing
twenty thirty hours of video games every
week we'll be in our facebook newsfeed
8:00 at night or watching movies left
and right watching sports all day long
sleeping in not working that hard
convincing everybody else that you're
working hard except you you really
believe that some tells me you already
know the answer to that question
and some tells me you also want your
dreams to become a reality
just keep this in mind you have your
dreams become a reality
you need to sacrifice your bad habits
will you maintain your habits and you
sacrifice your dreams they don't go to
the other one must go away your lose
want to gain the other one if you don't
do anything about it nothing will happen
see a bad credit score didn't happen
accidentally a bad credit score is a
reflection of bad financial habits
believe me I know that from personal bad
habits a bad health wait body didn't
happen accidentally slated now when no
one's watching and you're having a
cheese cake no savings in a bank account
they don't happen accidentally it's a
reflection of bad financial habits and
you and I not being successful didn't
happen accidentally that's a reflection
of bad habits that no one knows about
you know what sucks about bad habits
thirty forty years from now everyone's
gonna know by the bad habits because a
results will show that secretly they
were bad habits and nobody else me
nobody but you
children it's time we replace those bad
habits today with some good ones
I seem to go after your ranks
make a list of those two or three bad
habits
I'm dropping today
the dreams are waiting run he dreams are
counted
you